and the spirit award for best supporting
female is
ruth nigga
my cheeks hurt because i can't stop
smiling um this is a really lovely honor
um
i'm sorry i can't be there i'm
in rehearsing um for a play
um
but uh i just like to um
share this with the entire cast and crew
of passing
um
without who
um
there would be none there
and
especially
forest and margot and nina and of course
t tessa thompson and rebecca hall um and
then larson
nothing can be created in isolation
without anybody else
we create in solidarity with others and
um
so i feel like this is an award for all
of us um
and i'm just so proud to be part of such
a beautiful beautiful film um
and i'd like to express my solidarity
with the peoples of ukraine um
at this time um
i hope you all have a wonderful night
um i'd love to be there with you um
but it counts and
but um yeah
you are thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up from the big tent on the beach
andrew garfield presents the robert
altman award to an old friend plus
sebastian stan and better call saul's
bob odenkirk and ray seahorn